[Music]
I'm Michelle Miller from CBS Saturday
morning and welcome to the dish dough
and cheese and toppings are the key
ingredients in today's episode we're
talking all about the wonderful world of
pizza we had the San Francisco where the
unmistakable clamor of a busy restaurant
sounds a little different than you might
expect and to Las Vegas for an inside
look at the industry of pizza but first
we head to one of the most critically
acclaimed pizza joints in the country
and is right here in New York City where
Nate Burleson got the privilege of
eating what some say is the perfect pie
thank you have said that your
relationship with pizza
is like an addiction to a drug please
explain that to me because to be honest
I identify with that that's how much I
loved football I think the addiction to
the pizza is the idea also that like I
can never really reach the Finish Line
with I feel like the more I put into it
the more time I put into it the the
further away I actually get from the
idea of mastering it
Anthony mangieri talks about pizza the
way someone could describe the delicate
subtleties of Falling in Love
and to really understand where love like
that comes from
you need to understand its origin long
ago there wasn't really anyone in
America making the pizza that was from
Naples and you know my family is from
that part of the world and I used to
drive my grandmother crazy and she was
more of the kind of woman like a lot of
old school people were they were just
like I don't want to talk about anything
leave me alone and I was like but I want
to know this and I want to know that and
then as I got older and started to go to
Italy like it just
it connected with me so much it tasted
so different than like anything I had
eaten you know my original goal was to
like bring this like ethnic almost
exotic food to America Una Pizza
napolitana on New York's Lower East Side
is what you get after Decades of
refining the simple
the menu it's uncomplicated only pizza
here five different pies in the
ingredients mangieri keeps that simple
too now can you explain to me how
creating something so simple can be so
difficult you know when things are
really simple I think that's when it
actually can get complicated because
there's nothing to hide behind you know
it's almost like if you're you know in a
rock band and you're going to do your
solo concert and it's going to be like
you singing acoustic with nobody else
there's nowhere to hide it's similar
with making pizza and especially the way
we do it at UNO which is like pretty
straightforward pretty lightly topped
and really trying to let the very few
ingredients that we use sing you can get
lost in that
mangieri discovered his pizza Obsession
while in his teens he opened a bakery in
New Jersey when he was 22. and
established the first una at the Jersey
Shore in the 90s
he later moved that shop to Manhattan
and then to San Francisco before
settling back home here in New York City
our dough is the same way we've made it
since the beginning it's naturally 11 so
there's no yeast in it what that means
on some health sides is that it's easier
to digest we change the dough mixture
every day I don't think we've ever made
it really exactly the same no and I
don't write anything down either so some
days we come in and we're like oh my God
it's great and some days we come in and
like even today I was like dear God I
hope it worked last night get down
splashed across the pages of high
profile restaurant reviews mangieri's
work has been widely recognized thank
you Anthony here he is in the showtime
hit billion it's good to love what you
do enjoy guys and food critics of every
flavor have sampled and reviewed his
Neapolitan styled Pizza Pete Wells of
the New York Times said this about your
pizza
unmistakably the finest sit-down Pizza
in the five boroughs
does stuff like that go to your head
no no I mean man I feel so grateful like
to even be able to make pizza and do it
for a living actually I think when he
called me to fact check for that article
I was I pretty sure I said you don't
have to write about us you know it has
to drive you though and I I know you
drive yourself yeah I was gonna say I
mean I'm pretty self-driven and
self-motivated for more than a quarter
Century he's made nearly every bit of
dough and every Una Pizza himself this
oven reaches temperatures around 1000
degrees it only takes about 90 seconds
for a finished Pizza to emerge so you
take one scoop like this set it in the
center and kind of spin it around oh my
God that spoon and trust me it's harder
than it looks and you make pizza until
you're out of we make yeah we open at
five we make pizza till we're out of
dough along with our pizzas which we
have five very basic ones there's four
or toppings that you can add to those
those toppings are those toppings are
Parmigiano-Reggiano calabrian long hot
peppers which are amazing pepperoni but
it's not your average pepperoni it's
incredible and anchovies from the Amalfi
Coast
for mangieri quality product starts with
being open and being humble it's baked
into his personality and baked into his
pizza I don't think anything can stop
you it's like cause and effect yeah it's
the rules of the universe you know but
like you would know man playing sports
it's like you know you're not going to
be an NFL superstar
in five minutes like it's a lifetime of
like effort and struggle so the
mozzarella and it's the same with a
small business whatever it is if you
give it
people are going to come in they're
going to see it in much respect to y'all
this is tricky they're gonna get it
they're gonna understand that like this
is for real this is the truth we put it
on here yeah
and that like you were giving it your
all and I think it's undeniable and I
think you will find your success man I
can sit here all day long
thank you
up next are Jeff Gloria visits an
unlikely restaurant that ranks among the
world's most respected pizza places
literally
[Music]
when it comes to ranking the world's
best pizza you might not expect a little
spot in Western New York to make the
list but Against All Odds it did and
Jeff Laura went there for a taste
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
is a pizza Prodigy he studied first
under restaurateur Jay langfelder before
rounding out his training in Naples
Joe was always asking questions he
wanted to know what you were doing you
know it wasn't just make the pizza he
wanted to know why you want to know why
we did things a certain way and that
made you believe that he could do this
by himself I know he already was it was
it was fun and like it's it's a really
good experience like learning
learning
Joe and Jay's rapid rise to Global Pizza
superstardum gave us a chance to do an
Americanized dish dive into the world of
traditional Neapolitan Style
for the I initiated the difference
between neapolitan pizza and the pizza
you normally would have delivered to
your house so a neapolitan pizza is
cooked extremely hot extremely fast so
it's going to be much softer and kind of
a puffy Corner tone and it's going to be
a lot fresher of a pizza than something
you get in a box that was baked for
eight or ten minutes so ideally these
are eaten within minutes of coming out
of the oven
[Music]
pizza meant to be eaten hastily is best
prepared exactingly so I'm just going to
dump that in there
[Music]
we're just gonna put uh 10 grams of
yeast in and you're gonna kind of like
rub it in between your hands so we're
just gonna go like that and it's just
gonna fall right into the water
so then we're going to weigh out all the
flour
this is a Caputo double zero flower
what's double zero double zero is just
like the type of flower that it is if
you're going by like neapolitan pizza
like traditions double zero flour start
it we'll come back in seven minutes and
see what it looks like okay
once the mixture was complete Joe formed
the dough into 12 perfectly smooth round
bowls before introducing us to another
time-honored tradition
this is the Neapolitan slap yes yeah all
the pizza on Naples
that looks about good then we're gonna
bring it right there about a 12 inch
disc
my turn so now you're gonna get your
your hand like this yeah three fingers
underneath and you're like throwing it
and then you're also rotating it throw
and rotate yep
so throw it over yeah rotate it yeah
hey if it was easy everybody would do it
right that's close whoops yeah
[Music]
now it was time to give our pie a little
taste of the Old Country so we're gonna
do one scoop of the tomatoes that we get
from
um Italy then we're gonna go with a
little Parmesan reggiano gives it a
little bit of saltiness a little bit of
bite
this is some basil that we get from
somebody locally who grows it
hydroponically it's it's really really
great basil and we have a little bit of
a fresh mozzarella
spin it out like that do you want me to
put it on the peel and you launch it in
the oven no I'm doing the whole thing
doing the whole thing yeah all right
you're gonna SL you're gonna go one
quick motion slide right underneath
you're gonna lower lower your backhand
keep this flush the table and you're
gonna go straight through it
damn it
it's all right if at first you don't
succeed
ask a pro
ah you did it perfectly yeah okay all
that was left was to launch it into the
oven find your spot put it on it and
then one quick motion out yep angle it
down and pull it there you go like a
samurai yeah yeah and only about 60
seconds later our neapolitan pizza was
ready to eat
[Music]
again
the classic margarita was served along
with an induya pizza with chili honey
and basil fungi with confi garlic and
truffle pecorino the zuka with butternut
squash puree maple syrup and pumpkin
seeds and a pesto Neapolitan with
roasted tomatoes
Joe also threw in a Detroit style with
cherry peppers
for desserts
panna cotta what is it about neapolitan
pizza that you thought would work so
well
you know I had worked in Buffalo
pizzerias for forever and I love buffalo
style pizza as much as the next guy but
I just felt like this area was missing
all these other varieties of pizza that
you can find across the world and in the
US I mean it seems crazy to say that as
the goal is the goal eventually to have
the number one pizza it's a goal but I I
don't know
I don't know like it isn't it is it well
when Joe called me to tell uh tell me
that they were 13 in the U.S though I
think the first thing that came to both
of our minds is how do we get in the top
five
thank you
there is something special about this
next Story the food of course but also
the staff entirely owned and operated by
people who are deaf Tracy Smith
experienced the magic of mazaria in San
Francisco
foreign
ranked among the top pizza places in the
city and one of the first to be entirely
owned and operated by people who are
deaf thank you melody and Russell Stein
opened the place in 2011 and it's been a
foodie favorite from the start their 900
degree Wood-Fired oven is the best they
could find and so is every ingredient
where does the cheese come from we bring
that from Italy and we also make some
in-house
and if that doesn't make you hungry I
don't know what will noise isn't an
issue here and neither is communication
oh yeah where is it this one pointing at
the menu works just fine
and you can even phone in a takeout
order that glowing green light on the
wall signals an incoming call an
operator picks it up and translates your
order in Sign Language via closed
circuit TV but this is about a lot more
than serving hungry customers
how important is it to you to have an
all deaf staff
oh it's very important if a hearing
person say it doesn't work out here they
can find a job tomorrow no problem while
all the deaf people here have to look
for years and still can't find a job
that's when I decided I would have an
entirely deaf team even if they have no
work experience the critics like food
editor Paolo lucasi have been kind you
can feel the love in the in the food and
that's and it's just simple delicious
food that the kind of food you just want
on a Wednesday night
what does that do to your heart
it's still hard to believe
but I wouldn't trade it for anything in
the world
since this story first aired the
original mazaria has now become a food
truck and opened a new location in
Washington D.C after the break we head
to Sin City for the big business of
pizza profits this is the dish
the annual International Pizza Expo in
Las Vegas brings together thousands of
pizza makers and would-be business
owners and begs the question can
everyone get a slice of the pie Luke
Burbank weighs in
for one week every year the center of
the known Pizza Universe isn't Naples
Italy or New York or even Chicago
it's Las Vegas when the international
Pizza Expo rolls into town bringing with
it thousands of professional Pizza
makers
dough tossers
all right one TV reporter nervous about
his waistline let's do a little before
weigh in
and lots of aspiring pizzaiolos which is
Italian for people hoping to grab their
slice of the pizza business well I've
always loved baking and my four boys and
I we would every Friday make you know
make pizzas our pizza Fridays people
like Sherry Neal her dream of opening a
pizzeria started back when she was
living in a small Oregon Town working as
a baker and I would get requests for
pizza because we just didn't have a
great pizza place Neil came to Vegas to
join the ranks of the 42 000 or so
people in the U.S that own independent
pizza parlors and she's learning it
won't be easy they're just so many
pitfalls in opening a place that it's
amazing any place succeeds in fact
according to recent studies more than
half of restaurants that open fail in
the first few years but Scott Sandler's
shop pizzahead in St Louis is one of the
success stories and he's come to the
Expo to extol the virtues of of all
things vegan pizza vegan and vegetarian
is just growing like crazy Sandler who
used to work on Wall Street managing a
very different kind of dough was also
teaching a class on what he calls
restaurant math a lot of people get into
pizza and they're romantic about it but
they don't know what the hell they're
doing they don't know margins Anthony
Falco knows margins and Industry Trends
and really just about every aspect of
the pizza business and its knowledge
he'll share with you for a price because
you see he's an international Pizza
consultant which yes is really a job
most of the people say like that's
awesome I wish I had known that was a
job and I could do it and I'm like oh
it's really easy just spend 10 years
working 80 hours a week building one of
the most recognized Pizza brands in you
know the United States Falco got his
start at influential Pizzeria in
Brooklyn New York and has now helped
open restaurants on four continents part
of the global Pizza industry which is
worth an estimated 144 billion dollars
which is a lot considering it's often
sold at just a few dollars a slice you
can go pretty far on sauce and cheese
like the combination of hot cheese and
sauce is pretty epic and you throw
pepperoni on there wouldn't they say bad
Pizza is still pretty good that's what
they're talking about is the cheese
sauce combination the cooking of the
delicious pizza is like the easiest
funnest part consistency
operations like running a well tuned
machine is you know the really the hard
part but the key Falco says two really
really good pizza is its base the crust
is this the perfect food yeah this right
here this one this pizza this exact
Pizza is the perfect fit you know what I
mean just kind of like okay man you got
veggies you got herbs and well look
there you go no tip sag no tip sag yeah
cheers
aspiring pizza shop owner Sherry Neal
has been thinking about her crust for
years literally we're going to do a
Sourdough and my starter which is called
a mother is about 14 years old so it
makes an excellent crust oh wait a
second you the dough that you're going
to use for your restaurant
you've had the beginnings of that dough
for 14 years yeah it's like my
whenever we move we move cross country
oh Korean barbecue chicken speaking of
well-fed I had been feeding myself pizza
for three solid days
and finally it was time for a reckoning
and after three days of pretty much
continuous Pizza eating
oh boy the result was a pleasant
surprise actually just a couple of extra
pounds who knows maybe it is true what
they say and what happens in Vegas
really does stay there one can only hope
for more stories like these and live
coverage of breaking news 24 7 stream us
right here on CBS News I'm Michelle
Miller we'll see you the next time for
another helping of the dish
this episode of the dish is sponsored by
Prudential plan invest insure retire
with Prudential